bonjour chez chronique de profs on aime
la nature on vous avait déjà parlé de
l'histoire des forêts de la mer mais il
est un thème qui n'avait pas encore été
abordé les déserts la montagne qui est
par dr c'est pas faux la plupart des
montagnes sont vides
aujourd'hui moins de 0 18% de la
population mondiale vit au dessus de
3500 mètres soit un peu moins de 10
millions de personnes
bon exemple est un peu extrême mais si
on élargit un peu moins de 8% de la
population mondiale vit au dessus de
1000 mètres
là ça calme qu'en était-il dans les
temps reculés
que penser des hommes des montagnes qui
les entoure et comment ils vivent est il
une enquête signée la prof et moi et moi
et elle
[Musique]
pour cet épisode on parlera surtout des
montagnes françaises n'ont pas par
chauvinisme mais parce que je suis
surtout une historienne française qui a
étudié l'histoire française elle est
historienne de france les alpes surtout
sont à massifs particulièrement étudiée
qui reviendra fréquemment
bref la montagne et fréquenté depuis
longtemps les hommes de néandertal se
balader sur les versants des alpes il ya
des dizaines de milliers d'années pour
la chasse et la présence humaine laisse
des traces plus importantes à partir de
moins dix mille
ce n'est qu'au niveau des tic commence
l'exploitation des montagnes pour le
massif vosgien par exemple les
défrichements commence vers moins 5000
et progresse à partir de l'âge de bronze
va moins de milles les hommes
s'installent dans les fonds de vallée
pratiquent l'élevage et exploitent les
ressources minières des montagnes les
pierres qui servent à la fabrication de
différents outils et le cuivre
les hommes du néolithique sont donc
éleveurs mineurs et commerçants les
grands cols alpins sont déjà des voies
de passage qui facilite les échanges
l'occupation romaine à partir du 1er
siècle avant jésus-christ ne modifie pas
vraiment les villages qui sont déjà bien
développée mais permet de renforcer le
réseau routier dans les vosges par
exemple le massif est traversé par cinq
routes à partir de la conquête romaine
elle entraîne aussi le développement de
la viticulture sur les pentes parce
qu'il est bien connu que les romains et
les romaines adore la picole nous
apprécions aussi les fromages et
produits laitiers que ces montagnes et
un moment pour accompagner le 20 mai la
culture montagnarde reste sept voire
près seltz et avec les crises de la fin
de l'empiré romain
celles ci deviennent des lieux de refuge
et de résistance les populations des
alpes surtout deviennent mouvante
jusqu'à la christianisation au 6e siècle
mais là on arrive au moyen-âge et avant
ça on va faire un petit point mythologie
j'avais déjà un peu abordé le sujet dans
mon épisode sur les superstitions
mais les vieux des articles sont
particulièrement riche en légendes et
croyances
depuis l'antiquité grecque au moins on
attribue aux montagnes de nombreuses
légendes sur les origines des avalanches
débrouillard et autres phénomènes
naturels qui éveille forcément les
soupçons
d'autres histoires renforce ses
croyances au moyen-âge celle des démons
qui vivent sur le mont aiguille dans le
vercors ou encore les sabbats de
sorcières sur les sommets
voir notre épisode 14 sur le sujet ce
type de légende fait des sauts mais des
lieux inquiétant répulsif
aux formes étranges et immense qu'on se
contente de traversée par nécessité les
descriptions des voyageurs marchand
pèlerins sont souvent négatives dans
leur récit on trouve des informations
sur les routes le dénivelé les distances
mais s'attarde assez peu sur la beauté
du paysage
c'est le cas de félix fabrique qui
raconte son voyage à travers les alpes
au xvème siècle
nous sommes arrivés dans un certain
endroit par un très mauvais chemins
défoncés par la glace la neige et les
pierres ou la route royale avait été
totalement arrachés par des amas de
neige et de glace
en effet il était tombé la veille du
haut de la montagne des blocs de neige
qui avaient entraîné avec eux de grosses
pierres et des arbres retourner
jusqu'aux racines et le passage n'était
pas rouvert nous avons fait la traversée
avec grande peine
il est vrai que les voyageurs passent
par les contrées les plus reculées
tandis que les habitants des alpes
vivent des lieux plus propice et ça
mieux aborder la montagne on retrouve
cette distinction entre la montagne
vivable exploitables et cet ailleurs que
constituent les sommets dans les
descriptions des notaires il était
taillé parfaitement les ruisseaux des
prairies les cabanes d'alpage mais ne
parle jamais des sommets qui sont
d'ailleurs très peu nommés avant le
xviie siècle les gens des montagnes on
peut aussi leur lot de légendes et
d'idées reçues
ils sont décrits comme des gens frustrés
fou blasphémateurs alors qu'ils sont
souvent en très bons termes avec les
habitants des vallées
ils n'ont même pas une vie si différente
de leurs contemporains des plaines ne
peut pas vraiment parler de mode de vie
montagnards cette vision négative
s'explique par le climat rude qui incite
les voyageurs affaires des montagnards
le reflet de leur environnement la
montagne sauvage donc les montagnes 1 le
sont aussi
en plus ces voyageurs sont souvent
amenés à traverser plusieurs aires
linguistiques en franchissant les alpes
ou les pyrénées
et ça c'est perturbant imaginez un peu
des gens qui ne parlent pas notre langue
forcément des sauvages paradoxalement
les montagnes sont aussi dans de
nombreuses religions d intermédiaire
entre les hommes et les dieux on peut
citer par exemple le mont olympe ou le
sinaï
plusieurs auteurs du moyen-âge tente de
situer le paradis dans les montagnes
d'orient dans les mondes arménie ou sur
la classe il n'est pas étonnant alors
qu'elles deviennent des lieux de refuge
de nombreuses ermite choisissant de s'y
installer ou d'y construire des
chapelles ou décroît celles ci ont pour
fonction de christianiser le lieu est
d'en chasser toutes les créatures
fantastiques pourrait y vivre
un exemple home du milieu du xiiie
siècle résume le rôle de ces croix dans
le diocèse de tarentaise au dessus du
château de chevron il était une roche
très hot qui n'avait jamais pu être
gravitant elle était à brut
là se tenait fréquemment des assemblées
de démons et autres fantasmagorie de
partout on voyait des feux s'allument et
des flammes vaciller et des châteaux se
construire tout seul
les gens du lieu tard conseils pour
savoir ce qu'il convenait de faire et
gravir la montagne posèrent des croix de
bois au sommet depuis lors aucun des
monts n'ai aucune de ces lueurs n'a paru
plus à cet endroit
avec le développement de la littérature
merveilleuse bas moyen-âge des montagnes
serait aussi le domaine de créatures
magiques comme des dragons des griffons
ou des nains qui vivent dans les creux
des montagnes
d'autres pensent que le cristal et de la
neige des montagnes solidifier ou que
les torrents charrie or et pierres
précieuses
un autre groupe de légende que j'aime
beaucoup par le des rois dormant des
rois caché sous la montagne qui
attendrait pendant des centaines
d'années avant de réapparaître au moment
où on a besoin de tels des messies on y
retrouve le roi arthur dormant bien au
chaud dans un volcan en sicile mais
aussi l'empereur frédéric ii qui se
cacherait encore dans les monts de
curage 200 ans après sa mort ou encore
le roi de bohême wenceslas 2 il
arriverait aussi que des voyageurs se
retrouve au détour d'un col dans des
mondes parallèles dirigée par le roi
arthur en personne on peut noter que le
nom arthur vient du grec arthaud ce qui
signifie ours et où vivent les ours si
ce n'est dans des cavernes montagnarde
sur la banquise
nous en savons quelque chose pas de
mauvais souvenirs ici time warp la
vision des montagnes commence à changer
au 14e siècle à une époque où le
peuplement et le trafic en montagne
s'intensifient les premières ascensions
des sommets permettent une re découverte
de la montagne notamment celle de
pétrarque sur le mont ventoux qui aurait
eu lieu en 1336 que son récit soit vrai
ou faux il est le premier à décrire la
montagne d'une manière positive avec
intérêt et curiosité une autre ascension
importante est celle du mont aiguille en
1492 sur l'ordre du roi charles ix 8 un
gros coup de com pour montrer que ce
mont inaccessible ne l'était pas tant
que ça la montagne commence à être
regardées pour elle même pour saboter
une vision qui se développe au cours de
l'époque moderne
mais ça on y reviendra en fin d'épisode
une certaine vision scientifique des
montagnes existe aussi au moyen-âge
barthélémy l'anglais étudie la présence
des mines en montagne j'en demande ville
s'intéresse au climat particulier des
sceaux mais vincent de beauvais met en
avant l' air pur des montagnes qui fait
des montagnards des gens sains et fort
parce qu'il ne faut pas oublier que les
montagnes sont des lieux de vie
particulier j'osais des acosta écrit au
xvième siècle que les voyageurs qui
s'aventurent à haute altitude souffrent
de troubles sérieux
ces troubles sont le mal des montagnes
un manque d'oxygène pouvant mener à la
mort ni causé par une forte pression qui
entraîne une raréfaction de l'oxygène en
montagne l'augmentation du rayonnement
solaire les grandes différences de
températures sur une même journée
bien que cela ne concerne pas vraiment
l'europe au dessus de 2500 mètres les
populations montagnardes ont connu au
fil des générations d adaptation
biologique qui les empêche de souffrir
de ce mal des montagnes au tibet dans
les andes les habitants se sont adaptés
à l'altitude au point de souffrir
parfois d'un excès d'adaptation qui les
empêche de s'installer définitivement
dans les plaines pour pallier à cela les
rois un cas du coup ce qu envoyé leurs
troupes en garnison sur la côte par
roulement de deux mois avant de les
ramener dans les montagnes pour qu'il
reprenne des forces
revenons en maintenant au sixième siècle
où on avait laissé nos villages
montagnards on sait maintenant que les
montagnes françaises sont occupés depuis
bien longtemps et si vous en manquez
encore des preuves
on trouve dans les noms de villages des
empreintes prescelti xetic latine
francique et médiévale à partir du 6e
siècle les premières abbaye s'installe
dans les montagnes l'abbaye de saint
gall par exemple qui est fondée en 6 113
entre le 6e et le 12e siècle les massifs
français se couvrent d'abbaye fondée à
l'initiative de grand seigneur ne faut
pas en conclure pour autant que les
moines sont les grand défricheur des
montagnes ils exploitent leurs terres
certes mais leur principale utilité et
d'attirer les populations laïque sur ses
terres des colons qui met en valeur la
terre bâtisse les villages créé des
alpages etc
les nouveaux villages construits au
moyen-âge sont donc souvent créées par
des paysans sur l'initiative de
seigneurs laïcs ou religieux
en cela rien de différent entre les
villages de montagne et les villages des
plaines les monastères contribue aussi
au développement de la transhumance au
10ème siècle et développe la fabrication
du fromage
on peut prendre l'exemple de l'abbaye de
saint-michel de la clause qui reçoivent
du comte de genève la vallée de chamonix
1090 elle est déjà un peu habité et
cultivé mais surtout occupés par des
glaciers qui commence seulement à
reculer car l'europe connaît alors un
petit réchauffement climatique
les habitants vivent donc en fond de
vallée la belle décide de créer un
prieuré et sa seigneurie à chamonix
achève de faire des friches et le fond
de vallée puis fait créé par les paysans
des alpages sur les pentes des montagnes
à partir du xiiie siècle vers 1350 la
vallée de chamonix et ses montagnes sont
donc largement humaniser le peuplement
des montagnes consiste en de nombreux
hameaux plus ou moins dispersé
fédérer autour d'un chef lieu parfois
pas plus gros que les autres la plupart
de ces hameaux s'implante sur les fonds
de vallées qui sont aps le plat et
permettent donc mieux l'agriculture ou
sur les versants sud car
l'ensoleillement oyez maximale les
villages de montagne très étendues sont
donc divisés entre le fond de vallée le
pas des versants où se trouvent les
habitations permanentes et quelques
prairies les milieux deux versants où
l'on trouve des prairies et des forêts
et enfin les sommets où se créent les
alpages ce type d'étagement est décrit
au xvème siècle par un religieux de la
chartreuse du reposoir le lieu admirable
se rendit le symptôme est une vallée
profonde situés entre les montagnes
elle est tout à fait en propre à la
plantation d'arbres fruitiers et
insuffisamment fertile au milieu c'est
coule une rivière entouraient d'une
plaine étroite
c'est là que sont blotties des maisons
tout autour s'élève démonte surmonté de
roches est très élevé ils sont
recouverts de bois de pin et d'autres
espèces mais au sommet on trouve de
toutes parts des pâturages qui sont
excellents pour la nourriture du bétail
un joli paysage de montagne donc créé
par l'homme les maisons de montagne sont
bien des maisons le terme de chalets ne
désigne que des bâtiments d'alpage
jusqu'au développement du tourisme
ces maisons sont souvent construites sur
deux ou trois étages dont le premier
niveau est en pierre et le reste en bois
elles servent à la fois d'habitation
pour les hommes souvent au niveau
intermédiaire des tables pour les
animaux au niveau inférieur et de grange
pour le foin au dernier étage un cellier
savante à la conservation du fromage est
aussi intégré à la maison attendez
pourquoi on n'a pas de pièce à fromage
nous nous avons déjà ta chambre
des bâtiments d'alpage sont très
nombreux mais moins bien connu le
principal sert au logement des hommes et
à la fabrication du fromage et se nomme
cabana ou chavanat selon les lieux il ya
aussi des granges en bois où le fonds a
mis à sécher jusqu'à l'automne ou
l'hiver où il sera descendue sur des
luges quand la grange de la maison
principale sera vidée on y trouve aussi
des
prêts pour les bêtes et des prairies
intermédiaires et à proximité des vignes
sont construits de petits bâtiments
rassemblant les instruments nécessaires
à la viticulture
et puis vivre à la montagne comprend
quelques spécificités et quand je parle
de spécificités je veux dire des
contraintes et des risques la neige dans
une société où on ne connaît ni les
raquettes ni le ski ce n'est pas très
pratique parfois la neige prend la forme
d'avalanche entraînant les maisons avec
elle dans les zones à risque on constate
que l'habitat est beaucoup plus resserré
pour justement éviter de construire sur
des couloirs d'avalanche connu certains
villages conserve aussi un manteau
forestier au dessus des maisons pour
freiner la neige et les glissements de
terrain en fond de vallée les torrents
peuvent entrer en creux et pas mal
amoché les villages aussi et de manière
moins dramatique la pente et les
distances représentent des contraintes
pour les montagnards le relief isole les
hameaux les uns des autres les cols sont
parfois difficilement franchissable
nécessite l'entretien de routes et de
ponts la pente représente parfois un
avantage quand il s'agit de descendre le
foin ou les troncs à la luge
mais réduit aussi l'espace habitable et
cultivables dans certaines vallées des
alpes les paysans doivent s'encorder
pour faucher les prêts malgré leur
isolement les communautés alpine
présente de nombreuses formes de
solidarité avant même l'existence des
seigneuries et des paroisses il existe
des groupes informels les voisins les
hommes de des groupes présidée par les
chefs de famille qui se réunissent dans
le cadre du hameau on en trouve des
mentions à partir du 11e siècle mais il
existe probablement depuis plus
longtemps les liens du village passe
aussi par le mariage ce n'est pas une
exception montagnarde
on se marre et surtout dans le hameau ou
dans ceux d'à côté les communautés
montagnardes hoeness réellement en
réaction aux développements des
seigneuries face au seigneur
les paysans demandent une mise par écrit
de leur liberté sous la forme de charte
de franchise celle-ci réglemente l'accès
aux alpages l'usagé l'entretien des
communs certaines communautés peuvent
regrouper plusieurs hameaux plusieurs
paroisses et n'ont pas non plus les
mêmes pouvoirs
il y en a qui organise des réunions
périodiques d'autres disposent de
magistrats et l'assemblée permanente
qu'on aime consulat d'autres enfin sont
carrément des communautés de vale qui
regroupe plusieurs dizaines de villages
qui se rassemblent plusieurs fois dans
l'année sous la supervision du seigneur
et ont carrément des pouvoirs
judiciaires au 13ème siècle les grands
seigneurs s'implique davantage dans
leurs terres montagnarde ils
introduisent dans les petites seigneurie
de montagne leur propre vaisseau et font
également appel à la population locale
pour faire office de fonctionnaires il
peut s'agir de petit noble locaux ou
surtout de notables du village des
notaires ou des paysans aisés par
exemple les territoires de montagne
reste souvent des zones frontalières
qu'il faut donc bien maîtrisé le moteur
oui c'est là qu'il s'étend cette cité a
toujours été à portée de son ombre
une autre communauté importante et la
paroisse qui présente la particularité
d'être très étendue en montagne elle est
aussi plus récentes
alors que la plupart des paroisses en
europe sont créés entre le 10e et le
xiiie siècle dans les montagnes leur
création continue jusqu'au 15ème siècle
du fait des risques d'incendié
d'avalanche les églises et les
cimetières servent souvent de lieu de
stockage ce qui ne plaît pas trop aux
évêques avec l'éloignement entre les
hameaux et le village l'église peut
cependant être difficile d'accès en
hiver à cause de cela certains diocèses
autorise au 13ème siècle les parents a
baptisé directement leurs enfants malgré
toutes ces marques de solidarité il
existe aussi de grosse concurrence entre
communautés à mon époque une pratique
marrante consiste à piquer les bêtes du
hameau d'à côté et les manger tous
ensemble comme un rite
on appelle ça moutonné laver ou put your
et le bétail du 11e au 14e siècle la
montagne s'humanise donc de plus en plus
mais il reste un défi de quoi vite on
sur les montagnes la base de l'économie
et surtout de la survie c'est
l'agriculture pour ça les montagnes
c'est pas l'idéal l'agriculture
montagnarde est avant tout vivrière des
paysans de faire face aux risques de gel
qui peuvent survenir toute l'année au
dessus de 1500 m et aux risques de
chutes de neige précoces ou tardives des
moissons peuvent être repoussée jusqu'à
la toussaint et les semailles sont donc
repoussées jusqu'à l'année suivante ou
remplacés par des céréales de printemps
- bon à faire du pain de plus les sols
sont de mauvaise qualité et de nombreux
sérielle ne pousse pas au dessus d'une
certaine attitude
les habitants de servières témoigne de
la situation en 1434 notre territoire
est stérile très montagneux est situé en
alu mauvais et dangereux
nous y récolte ont trop peu de blé et de
foin pour assurer notre subsistance à
l'exception de quatre ou cinq d'entre
nous nous sommes obligés chaque année
d'acheter du blé les champs et les prêts
sont très dispersées et très étroit les
habitants profitent du moindre espace
disponible malgré la pente
on cultive surtout le seigle l'orge
l'avoine le sarrasin à partir du 15e
siècle et on plante quelques vergers et
vignes pour le vin des difficultés de
l'agriculture en d'élevage
indispensable pour fumer ses terres et
pour accompagner ces serial de quelques
produits laitiers la plupart des paysans
possède donc quelques vaches moutons ou
chèvres d'autres ressources locales sont
exploitées le bois par exemple est
souvent employé et réemployés dans la
construction les forêts servent aussi
aux chauffages à la cueillette de la
mousse des fruits des pommes de pin à la
confection de charbon de bois ou de
produits d'artisanat le bois de la
montagne et conduit vers la vallée par
flottage comme j'en avais déjà parlé
dans ma vidéo sur les forêts chronique
de profs numéro 27
l'eau des torrents et canaliser on est
loin des barrages hydroélectriques
mais des moulins à eau et forget
hydraulique se multiplient dans les
montagnes des pyrénées et des alpes à
partir du 14e siècle les ruisseaux
permettent aussi dérogations ou
constituent des étangs pour la
pisciculture la pêche bien que contrôlée
par le seigneur constitue une
alimentation d'appoint pour les
montagnards qui ont dans le droit enfin
la roche est exploité pour la
construction des maisons et des églises
on trouve aussi dans les montagnes des
carrières d'argile et quelques mines de
fer de plomb d'argent ou d'or à tester
dès le douzième siècle quand on pense
aux montagnes on pense beaucoup à la
transhumance
cette migration des sommets vers les
vallées ou dévaler vers des sommets pour
faire pâturer le bétail
la plupart des éleveurs ne possède que
quelques bêtes comme je le disais plus
tôt et font donc la transhumance avec
leurs animaux en famille dans de petits
chalets où elle fabrique directement
leurs fromages ou partie de la famille
reste en bas pour s'occuper des chants
et des prêts on appelle cette pratique
la petite montagne la grande montagne
consiste alors à rassembler les
troupeaux du hameau est allé confier à
un alpagistes un berger
le lait est aussi mis en commun et
transformé en fromage dans le chalet
collectif tandis que les propriétaires
des troupeaux reste dans la vallée et
s'occupe des moissons tranquillement le
berger a l'interdiction de quitter la
montagne avant la fin de la mission et
doit dédommager le propriétaire pour
tout animal perdu toutes ses
exploitations notamment l'élevage ouvre
les habitants des montagnes commerce et
permettent à certaines familles de
s'enrichir comme je le disais plus tôt
les montagnes sont parcourus au moins
dès le 9ème siècle par des pèlerins en
route vers rome où jérusalem mais aussi
par des marchands qui transitent entre
les foires de champagne d'allemagne et
d'italie surtout à partir du xiiie
siècle le péage de jougne dans le doubs
enregistre un passage tous les deux
jours en 1340 le transport
marchandises et coûteux la poste de cpe
âgée de quelques quoi un brigand mais
moins risqués que par la mer certains
montagnards participent à ce commerce
européen en se faisant 10 de montagne
transporteurs de marchandises ou en
commerçants eux mêmes à barcelonnette
par exemple les habitants pratiquent du
14e au 19e siècle le marchandage
saisonniers d'octobre à avril
ils font la tournée des villages avec
leurs marchandises à dos d'âne ou
d'hommes et vente des tissus
principalement ce sont les colporteurs
dont les enfants imitent le métier en se
faisant montreur de marmottes vous
joueur de vielle dans les villages
d'autres paysans vendent le produit leur
élevage dans des foires qui se tiennent
de plus en plus ou en montagne à la fin
du xiiie siècle on en trouve une âpre a
raillé à plus de 2000 mètres d'altitude
mais les plus importantes sont celles de
saint gervais et de briançon à la fin du
moyen-âge les villes ne cesse de gonfler
et donc d' importer du blé et des
produits laitiers
cette forte demande profite aux alpes
qui se tourne vers un élevage spécialisé
à but commercial
mais aussi à toute la provence de plus
en plus d'éleveurs des plaines l'eau des
terres dans les alpages pour participer
à la transhumance et sont plus ou moins
toléré par les montagnards ont par le
d'exode rural pour désigner la
désertification des campagnes
mais contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait
croire en montagne ces mouvements sont
rarement définitif des montagnes en
pratique depuis longtemps la migration
saisonnière pendant l'hiver dans les
hautes vallées du queyras et du
briançonnais un tiers des maisons reste
occupé pendant sept saisons
certains paysans pratiquent la
transhumance inversée allant faire
pâturer leurs bêtes dans les plaines
durant l'hiver par an soit entre hommes
soit avec leurs familles entières
ce qui ne garde pas les animaux vont
alors mendier glané où se louer pour
travailler dans les champs les mines ou
les ports ces migrations montre les
difficultés de vivre en montagne surtout
pendant l'hiver où tous les travaux des
champs sont interrompus ce qui reste
travaille alors dans l'artisanat ou dans
le textile certaines régions alpines se
spécialisent c'est le cas des habitants
de la suisse centrale qui se font
mercenaires au point de se retrouver en
1500 dans une bataille ou soldats des
deux camps
qu'ils viennent des mêmes valais ils
fraternisent alors et livres l'un des
chefs mylan et au roi de france
d'autres vivre définitivement espérant
fuir leur misère en se faisant
domestique ou soldats en s'enrichissant
grâce au commerce
certaines familles montagnards de vont
s'installer dans les villes des vallées
comme grenoble ces migrations ne sont
pas propres montagne l'exode rural
existe dès le xvème siècle et concernent
des bretons les picards tous les
habitants des campagnes attirés par les
villes en pleine expansion pour autant
les relations avec la montagne demeure
certains anciens montagnards vont ils
chercher leurs femmes d'autres possèdent
encore quelques terres certains et
retourne aussi parce qu'ils ont échoué
en ville ou par nostalgie je veux revoir
au 19e siècle l'industrialisation
renforce cet exode mais facilite aussi
les communications le train arrive dans
les montagnes de savoie en 1856 les
années 20 modifie encore la vie en
montagne puisque l'essor du tourisme
montrent l installation d'une nouvelle
population des notables venus des villes
des entrepreneurs venus investir dans
l'hôtellerie parce que oui il faut bien
on arrivé à ce moment où la montagne
attirent et éveille la curiosité à
partir du xviiie siècle des
scientifiques se rendent sur la montagne
pour étudier la géologie la physique la
chimie
et puis rapidement la montagne se
mettent à plaire pour son esthétique
avec l' influence des lumières et du pré
romantisme on se met à aimer la nature
et à vouloir explorer les derniers
espaces encore inconnue c'est le premier
motif de l'api nisme qui apparaît à la
fin du xviiie siècle atteindre un sommet
vierge dans l'histoire de l'irak cède la
première ascension du mont blanc est
effectuée par deux montagnards en 1786
mais l'histoire retient surtout celle du
savant bénédict de saussure un an plus
tard les ascensions se popularise dans
toute l'europe mais reste un loisir de
la bourgeoisie la visite des glaciers la
contemplation des sites pittoresques
devient le tourisme par excellence du
début du 19e siècle les anglais surtout
gravissent plus du tiers des sommets
vierges européens et sont les premiers à
créer un alpine club à londres ville de
montagne par excellence en 1857 la
france conserve une approche plus
scientifique et culturel le club alpin
français est fondée en 1874 publie
régulière
des articles scientifiques littéraires
et culturelles sur la montagne et son
ascension fréquenter les montagnes
présente aussi un intérêt sanitaires les
médecins du début du 19e siècle
recommande l'air de mer ou d'altitude
pour redonner de la vitalité et
fortifier les malades notamment les
tuberculeux des sanatoriums ouvre en
montagne et proposent à leurs patients
de se promener sur les sentiers de
profiter des forêts de pins ou de
s'allonger dans les galeries à errer au
soleil au cours du 20e siècle on en
arrive à une situation compliquée en
montagne celle-ci se dépeuple de leurs
habitants mais sont prises d'assaut par
les stations de ski qui se popularise
dans les années 60
à cette époque on pense que les
montagnes sont sauvés de nouveaux
emplois paraissent nouvelles populations
s'installent en montagne mais avec du
recul on constate que le solde
migratoire montagne reste négatif les
stations de ski s'installe sur d'autres
versant ce à l'ombre ou la neige reste
abondante
contrairement aux populations
montagnardes ancien qui recherchait tout
le contraire la montagne ce vide donc et
les parcs nationaux créés au xxème
siècle symbolise bien ce territoire du
vide
ce sont des territoires dans lesquels
l'homme doit intervenir le moins
possible alors qu'on a bien vu que les
montagnes sont largement parcouru est
défriché par les hommes du moyen-âge
andré micoud sociologue écrit il reste
juste assez d'habitants dans le paysage
juste assez pour que le risque de
dégradation des patrimoines soit le plus
faible possible pour que l'espace soit
rendue possible aux plaisirs des
citadins pour que la nature ouvrages et
par des siècles de travail paysans
puissent encore être offerte aux
contemplation réalisant tno stahl gic et
aux spéculations touristique pour que
les derniers milieu naturel restent
encore accessibles aux observateurs de
la faune et de la flore j'espère que cet
épisode vous a plu j'aime beaucoup cette
approche culturelle des relations entre
les hommes est un milieu naturel et
c'est pour ça que je me devais de faire
la montagne un jour la prochaine vidéo
sera une gente dame badass sur une femme
dont je n'ai pas encore décidé de
l'identité
alors en attendant vous pouvez toujours
rester chez vous tant que durera le
confinement et vous occupez en multi pan
sur tipi ou your type cloud en
partageant cette vidéo si vous regardez
ceux ci après le confinement youpi on
s'en est sorti et si vous regardez ceux
ci en étant le dernier à rome sur terre
et bien bravo à vous et à bientôt
il quitte un an
le pays pour s'en aller gagner leur vie
loin de la terre où ils sont mais depuis
longtemps il en rêvait de la ville et de
ses secrets du fort nika et du ciné les
vieux ça n'était pas original quand il
s'essuie et machines halte à revers de
manche les lèvres mais ils savaient tous
à propos tu es la calle le père d'eau et
manger la tomme de chèvre pourtant que
la montagne est belle
comment peut-on s'imaginer en voyant un
vol d'hirondelles que l'autre 1/2 vient
d'arriver
[Musique]